the jurogan experience the perils
of becoming famous when you're young are
well known right it's no one is really
there's
made a small handful of people that have
made it through unscathed
it's a it's a weird way to grow up
because
everybody else grows up trying to
prove their worth or trying to
find their place in life and trying to
you know get people to understand who
they are
you grow up where basically most people
who run into you
know who you are before you know who
they are and they're they're already
like
kind of freaked out that you're there
and they'll do anything for
you and they want to see you and they
want to see you perform they just want
to see you sing and talk
and it's a very strange way to grow up
right what did did you at any point in
time
have this feeling like hey maybe this
isn't the best way to grow up
so i grew up in texas
dallas texas um i keep forgetting we're
in texas
dallas um but i i grew up
you know i went to public school except
for the one year that i
homeschooled on barney and friends and
i experienced um bullying pretty bad
while i was there and so i ended up
leaving public school
and i went into a really depressive
state
for a period of time i didn't you know
when you're 12 and you're bullied that's
your social life like your social life
is everything to you and so um
i felt like i didn't have much to
look forward to anymore except for my
music and music kind of kept me alive so
it's not that like i ever looked at
the industry as um
this kind of weird burden on my
teenage years or whatever like yes it it
is weird in hindsight but i looked at it
as it actually kind of saved my life
at times because it gave me something to
live for and i knew that if i stayed in
texas
that um i wouldn't make it out alive
the bullying was that bad yeah the
bullying was that bad but
this just they knew that you had been on
television already so was that part of
the reason why they were bullying you
so when i asked them like why are you
guys so it all started with like
i wrote a note you know you're in
seventh grade you're passing notes back
and forth and i called someone
this other girl like called her annoying
and said she was being a [ __ ]
right and then that escalated to
by the end of the day i it was that like
scene in the movie where you walk in the
lunch room and everyone just looks at
you because the
the thing was is like the girls that i
wrote that about were the popular girls
and so it just like anyone who wanted to
be popular took their side
and everyone just was like i don't know
so
i had a concert that weekend on a
military base and
i went to like vegas for the the concert
or something and
when i came back it just had increased
and so
when i asked them like why are you guys
doing this i wrote a note we all write
notes in school we're in seventh grade
that's what we do
and they were just like well you're a
[ __ ] and you're
fat and so i internalized what they were
saying
and that's when my eating disorder
developed and
i couldn't i mean i wasn't a [ __ ] um
i believe you yeah
[Laughter]
it is so crazy how children have this
instinct to pile on to people like that
though it's
bullying is it's more common than not
right
well and you have to understand is my
generation was like the first with
social media so
what i was really um dealing with was
the cyber bullying
of everything it wasn't i had wished
that
someone had tried to fight me because
i'm a fighter and so i would have thrown
down
but they were coming at me with words
that scarred me emotionally for years to
come and
ended up you know scarring me for the
rest of my life
um and i i kept saying to people who
didn't
understand cyber bullying like i wish
that someone had just hit me and gotten
it over with because
at least i wouldn't have to live with
those words that they said to me
for years and that's what was the
hardest part
um was the emotional trauma of like of
all of it and which made it hard to
meet fans my age because i had just been
bullied three years before by people my
age
when i was meeting fans i was excited to
meet them but at the same time i knew
what they were capable of so i had this
weird like
battle in my head every time i'd meet
someone my age of like
i'm so appreciative of you but i'm also
terrified of what you're capable of
wow so you just had a wall up for any
young
kids that reminded you of the girls who
bullied you
which was my fan base at that time and
so that
was always in my mind and and i actually
never even told anybody that
really because i didn't think it was
important i also felt guilty for feeling
that way towards my fans
did you discuss the bullying with
anybody at the time oh yeah
i discussed it with my mom she took it
we went i mean she
came to the school and tried to tell
them what was happening and they were
like if it's cyber bullying we can't do
anything about it it doesn't happen on
school grounds
so no punishment really took place and
i mean they had a suicide petition that
they passed around the school
and tried to get people to sign it so
that i would kill my like it's
it gets gnarly and and girls can be
mean yeah middle school girls can be
mean and so
i talked about it a lot and then i
decided that was really my first taste
of
activism work was being an advocate for
anti-bullying
and i remember i like decided to start
talking about it and i felt like
i felt some purpose and all of a sudden
my career wasn't about my talent anymore
have you ever run into those girls
so i haven't run into them but i did
make a phone call to like the main girl
that bullied me because
when i got sober a part of the program
they teach you to
on your ninth step as you make amends
and
when you do your resentments um or you
you make a
list of resentments you write down
everyone you've had a resentment
against your entire life at least this
is the way i was
brought through the steps and her name
was on it and when they had me go
through
what was my part and i was like well i
put the name down that she was a [ __ ]
so like i guess i did play a part in
that
and when i looked at everything i was
like you know
i can't look back at that situation and
and
say that i was innocent so i went to own
my part but a part of the step
was calling and making amends and so i
called her
and she was like oh my gosh i can't even
believe you remember who i am and i was
like
[ __ ] you ruined my life like
are you [ __ ] kidding me
[Laughter]
and i was so i just like sat there and
was like cool i think this concludes the
end of this phone call
i'm sorry and i wish you well
was she did you get past that did you
talk to her like
she was so thrown off that i even
remembered who she was
after becoming famous and a celebrity
that like
she wasn't interested in talking about
what had happened when i was
12 or when we were 12. what did she want
to talk about like what's it like to be
you
like how are you like oh my god i miss
you so
much i hope you're well and i was just
like
[Laughter]
god grant me the serenity to accept the
things i cannot change isn't it
it's so strange people that are not
famous
for some reason they think that people
who are famous are not people
yeah you become a famous person you're
not a person it's like you have like a
shield around
you you you like all your emotional
scars or all of your past
right you know for some reason that
doesn't it doesn't affect you
you're in a castle somewhere covered in
gold
right yeah yeah they think that like
that's probably how she felt when she
was talking to you like how do you
remember me like
you're in a castle covered in gold and
so i'm hearing this thinking like
i've i just got out of treatment for an
eating disorder
like you don't think i remember you
you were the first person to ever call
me or not the first but
like you were the first mean girl to
call me fat
like of course i remember you it was
just wild but you know you look back at
times like that and
everybody like those were my teachers at
that time
like we all have teachers yeah and and
people
and so even though i
i used to resent that person for many
years i look at that time in my life and
i'm like well i needed to learn those
lessons then and
um is what it is can't change the past
it's a painful lesson that hangs with
you for that long but did you feel a
large weight lifted off you
after having that conversation with her
i know no felt the same way no it
actually
it made me more upset because i was like
how does someone who
literally altered the course of my life
not that i'm blaming her for my eating
disorder i would have probably developed
one anyways because my mother had one
and so
i was i was looking at negative food
behaviors and that's all i knew and so
when someone called me fat i knew
exactly what to do
now like i said i don't blame her for it
but um i couldn't believe that she
didn't think i remembered who she was
after what she said
made me decide to
stop eating yeah i just
but what i said earlier i just don't
think that someone like her
ever thinks that someone like you even
has normal feelings yeah totally and a
lot of people still think that about
celebrities
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience